Varför kan man aldrig prata svenska när man pratar investeringsspråk?
Ja men det är för att då blir det aldrig någon breakoutartikel kanske.
Jag förstår, de jobbar inte med Google Translate på catchphrases.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag ser det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Lina Wallmander till podden.
Hon är partner på Red Pill Invest och möjligen den enda investeraren som inte bor inom en kilometer från Stureplan, utan du bor i stället utanför Kungsbacka i Onsala.
Det måste vara ett jävligt udda ställe för en investerare.
Får du någonsin höra att det här är weird?
Hej Lina!
Hej!
Ja men får jag det?
Jag vet inte om jag avslöjar mig på den punkten kanske.
Det är så mycket möten som hålls digitalt, så det kanske är nu den stora nyheten släpps då kanske.
Jag fattar, okej alla tror att du ändå bor längs Birgjansgatan.
Exakt så.
Då ska vi inte säga någonting, vi klipper bort det sen.
Kan du inte ge oss lite, en liten summering av dig själv som människa.
Du behöver liksom inte berätta vad dina barnomskompisar hette, men liksom några små korta nedslag i din historia.
Ja, nej men jag är ju en gammal smålänning.
37 år, har en bakgrund som marknadschef från första början och rört mig i tech-svängen det senaste decenniet egentligen, i ganska varierande kontext, alltifrån små, små idéer som sedan bildas till bolaget, där man har varit med i skadningsresa till lite mer etablerade bolag.
Och, nej men har väl min huvudprofetis i kommunikation och marknad, då där sen equity och investeringar har blivit en naturlig påkoppling då.
Så att, sen har jag gått över till att ta en investerare-roll, både privat och som partner på Red Bill Invest.
Okej, du investerar även som person.
Ja men det har hänt, absolut.
Och sen så har man väl en liten portfölj från tidigare bolag där man har varit verksam då.
Så det är absolut en liten mix.
Jag fattar, får du avslöja något av de som är dina privata?
Ja, vad har jag nu, höll jag på att fråga mig.
Just nu har jag ägandet i Orbi i Cappie inom Fintech.
Jag har varit inne i Björn-Pornas Benges bolag, hans holdingbolag.
Det är jag uten nu.
Jag har ägt inom Automotive.
Så det är väl lite privata innehav som har varit.
Om du gör så privat och du jobbar med detta, är det liksom det ni snackar om här hemma?
Det är investeringar och bolag.
Har du några andra intressen?
Du har några kaniner här nere.
Ja, nej vi pratar ganska lite om investeringar hemma faktiskt.
Ja men privat, jag har precis börjat gymma.
Det är väl den naturliga kopplingen till er då.
Men jag lever ett ganska stillsamt liv.
Jag tycker om att jobba.
Det här är väldigt mycket för mig, ett sätt att leva.
Och där man är med då, bolagen är med och motgångar.
För ofta är det ju så att när man kommer in i den här svären med bolag som ska växa väldigt mycket, väldigt snabbt och helst väldigt kontrollerat också, i bästa fall, då är du ju många gånger samma människor som du träffar på i en ägarkonstellation eller man träffas i styrelserummet eller någon tar en ledande roll i ledningsgrupp.
Så att det blir liksom ett ekosystem du jackar in i.
Och så fort du börjar komma in i ägarlisterna eller styrelsearbetet, då blir det också lite gråzon som är arbete och intressen.
Och det är lurare sig där man bäst behövs helt enkelt.
Vad är din kompetens?
Vad är det folk efterfrågar när du kommer in som person?
Ja, oj, vad svårt att göra den analysen alls själv.
Du behöver aldrig sälja in dig, de bara frågar.
Jo, absolut.
Ibland behöver man ju kunna motivera.
Min profetis ligger ju i IR-kommunikation och att kunna hantera ägarfrågor och äga kommunikation.
Och titta på kapitalanskaffningsstrategi, inte bara utifrån ett finansiellt perspektiv, utan kanske mer det som handlar om att sätta sig in i de potentiella nya investerarnas intresse och argument.
Och kunna översätta det till en vd, eller till en ledningsgrupp eller en styrelse som står inför en ny emission eller liknande.
Vad behöver vi göra, vad kommer att vara i ett business case?
Ska vi se till att de här gates infiras innan vi går ut på den här marknaden?
Vad kommer att vara bäst gynnsam för bolaget?
Och sitta som en brygga mellan de här nya investerar-dialogerna, men också bolaget då.
Och när jag går in i investerar, och det är ju när jag sitter på bolagsidan eller som konsult då, men från investerarperspektiv så vill man ju veta att det finns en kunskap och en insikt om hur det faktiskt är att driva bolaget också.
För det finns ju pengar och det finns pengar.
Vad menar du med pengar och pengar?
Ja men så här.
Vad är det lite tystare pengar och vad är det högljudda pengar?
Det finns ju passivägare och det finns aktivägare.
Tittar man på bolaget tidigare faset så kommer det ju vara ganska aktuellt.
Förmodligen att ta in en strategisk investerare som kan vara med och etablera dig på en ny marknad eller som är bryggad till nya investeringar, som kan vara med och titta på bolaget med objektiva ögon, utan att väva in för mycket, det finns ju alltid ägerintressen såklart, med för mycket känslor som kanske en grundare exempelvis besitter då.
Så jag tror att där vill man ha förståelsen, eller bolagen vill ha förståelsen att de vet vad vi pratar om.
Vi kommer kunna ställa upp en utmaning eller problemformulering och få hjälp.
Det här är inte vi mot dem, utan så fort man hamnar på en ägarlista, då är det gemensamma intressen som gäller.
Och bolaget ska då verka för alla investerarnas intresse.
Då är du liksom inte mitt bolag som grundare längre.
Så det tror jag kanske, det är nog perspektivet som man kommer med.
Förhoppningsvis.
Det är ett jävla stort perspektiv.
Kan du ibland känna att vad flummigt det blir?
Ja, jo men det kan det bli.
Jag kan känna så här ibland att oj vad lätt det hade varit om det bara var ett finansiellt perspektiv.
Eller vi bara satt och räknade på siffror och ville se liksom att det finns ett positivt kassaflöde exempelvis.
Men så är det ju inte.
Vi investerar ju i onoterad miljö.
Det vill säga bolag som inte ligger på börsen.
Och då handlar det ju om mycket mer andra faktorer.
Det vill säga vad det för grundare, vad har man för, är det ett tillräckligt stor marknad, vad har man för hypotetiska möjligheter framöver som kan liksom, där det kan komma en hävstång i värderingsutveckling så att vi ska kunna få avkastning på det som vi investerar.
Är det ett solitt team?
Många gånger så pratar man ju jävligt mycket om grundare, men man tittar ganska lite på teamet.
Men du kommer ju aldrig att hitta en grundare som är allt, utan du behöver ju ha en grundare som har en tillräckligt schysst självinsikt för att också veta hur man ska bygga upp sina styrk och svagheter runt omkring sig.
Finns det vissa grundadrag som är väldigt typiska?
Är de ofta duktiga på en viss grej?
Är de ofta säljare eller marknadsföring?
Finns det en sort som är bättre, som du känner dig tryggare med, eller ni då?
Jag brukar ofta titta på att jag tycker om att se grundare som har en väldigt specifik kunskap i marknaden man ska verka i, eller en exceptionell förståelse för kundgruppen om den är ganska generisk.
Sedan föredrar jag ju om vd är en ganska omgyll som grundande vd när samma person då har förut sig, att den också är en ganska duktig generalist.
Det är ju ganska troligt att man annars hamnar i ett läge där det brister under finansiella kunskaper.
Då kommer man att förbise de delarna och när man börjar skala bolaget, kommer man att ge tillräckligt mycket mandat eller ha tillräckligt mycket förståelse mot sin CFO för att kunna driva den linjen.
Samma sak på marknad och marknadsföring, kommunikation och så vidare.
Eller produktutveckling eller vad det nu än är.
Någon form av kombination mellan specialist och generalist kanske.
Och framförallt att man fattar att man inte fattar det.
Ja men verkligen.
Eller kanske vikten av det då.
Alltså verkligen.
Alltså självinsikten och att bara uppleva som en autentisk människa som ser sig själv som en sammansättning i det här teamet som ska leda bolaget framåt.
Det tror jag är jätteviktigt.
Hamnar du någonsin i möten där du känner fan vilket bra bolag och fan vad smart den här människan är.
Men vilken tråkig ävel.
Kanske inte i att de är tråkiga men alltså mer liksom.
Du bara märker ditt personlighetsdrag, du inte tycker om och så är man körd.
Ja, alltså ska jag vara själv.
Jo men det är klart att man kan göra att man tänker att det här kanske inte var det mest karismatiska.
Men där får jag ju titta på mig själv.
Vad tittar jag med på för ögon.
Alltså ska jag ställa högre krav på den jag sitter och pratar med så måste jag göra det samma mot mig själv.
Men där är vi ju alltid ett team som utvärderar både teammedlemmar och bolagen tillsammans.
Så det är klart att mina andra partners på RedPills ser andra saker och kvaliteter som inte jag ser.
Jag skulle nog inte ha ratat ett bolag för att det är en trökig person.
Om jag tror att personen kan göra jobbet och är det så att det finns ett säljansvaro och så vidare.
Det är klart att man ställer sig i frågan om man kommer kunna leda den typen av satsning.
Men å andra sidan då är det ju bara att anställa en jävligt karismatisk säljchef eller marknadschef exempelvis.
Jag förstår.
Kan vi inte ta lite kort här om Red Pill Invest.
Vad är det för någonting och vad, nu för tiden känns det alltid som att alla ska särskilja sig på något sätt.
Hur särskiljer ni er och gör ni det på något sätt?
Ja men gör vi det.
Ja men kanske i vissa delar.
Red Pill Invest är ju ett mindre investmentbolag som startade 2021.
För oss som inte har 100 miljoner, vad är ett mindre investmentbolag?
Ja men ett mindre investmentbolag, detta är ju kanske det som är särskilt ändå.
Vi bedrivs ju inte som en klassisk fond, det vill säga att vi har jättestor pengar på oss som vi sitter och disponerar.
Utan det som vi besitter är ju ett litet slutet investeringsnätverk där vi har med investerare som investerar tillsammans med oss.
Så det gör att vi är helt fria vad vi vill gå in i för bolag.
Vi har inga kravställningar på oss att bara gå in i specifika faser eller branscher eller nischer eller liknande eller att vi måste ta en viss ticket size.
Utan det som vi gör är att vi letar reda på rätt bolag som vi tycker att det här är det vi vill titta på just nu.
Och här tror vi att vår lilla grupp av investerare det här är en skitspart för oss och det är dit vi vill röra oss.
Men är det alltid samma investerare som går in eller är det olika?
Ja det är helt slutet nattverk så det är inte någonting som går ut publikt utan en liten sammansättning med större privata investerare kan man säga.
Och där vi sen helt enkelt syndikerar.
Så var det en person lägger en insats för en investering och sen så skapar man ett SPV, som äger investeringen tillsammans i det som vi går in i.
Och SPV betyder?
Åh, Gud.
En synkronisering av...
Investeringen?
Ja.
Jag fattar.
Och bara för att få någon sorts känsla för spannet här, vad är liksom den minsta investeringen ni har gjort och den största, och vad är de två ytterligheterna på branscher eller genrer?
Bara så att vi som lyssnare får någon sorts förståelse för.
Jag tror den minsta investeringen som vi har gjort ligger kanske runt två miljoner i något tidigt skede.
Vår take är att vi vill inte bli majoritetsägare eller liknande, utan vi vill vara en minoritetsägare, men vi är ofta ganska aktiva och det är inte från oss partners, utan det kan vara en representant ifrån den här investeringsgruppen eller liknande och där det kan handla om en styrelseplats eller ett advisory board eller liknande.
Den största investeringen, ja men det ligger väl gånger, några gånger den tvåan där då.
Får man inte säga?
Jo, det får man väl, vad kan det ligga på, en 6-7 kanske.
Så att vi är inte jättestora men vi är heller inte de minsta.
Så det är väl en fin mix där emellan.
Och jag tror att när vi sitter med bolag så handlar det om att vi kan röra oss ganska snabbt, vi är ganska okomplicerade, vi är inte långa del i processer än fast vi gör ett gediget förarbete.
Men vi förstår vitten av att kunna vara ganska agila och då är det väl rimligt, alltså ganska mycket pengar för en ganska schysst process helt enkelt.
Jag fattar.
Och kan du ge oss några exempel på branscher som ni har gått in i eller företag?
Jag vet att ni har investerat i Voj till exempel, det känner väl de flesta till som bolag.
Ja men det känner ju de flesta till.
Finns det något som absolut inte är elskotra?
Ja absolut, Soundtrack Your Brand är absolut inte elskotra.
Och det är väl ett bolag som är lite senare skede också då, tillsammans med Voj som vi har gått in i.
Och vi har gått in i Papershell inom Impact och New Materials.
Vi är inom Security, vi har skett någon investering i e-handel och retail fashion.
Så det är ett ganska brett spann, men skulle man generalisera vad vi vill titta på framöver, så är det väl främst inom MedTech, LifeScience, Impact, SaaS-bolag och AI.
Varför kan man aldrig prata svenska när man pratar investeringsspråk?
Ja men det är för att då blir det aldrig någon break-it-artikel kanske.
Nej jag förstår, jag förstår, de jobbar inte med Google Translate på catchphrases.
Apropå break-it då, enligt break-it har ju allting stått stilla här i två år, två och ett halvt kanske.
Har er process sett ut så också?
Pimplar ni mest kaffe här i två och ett halvt år och väntar?
Och nu börjar det snart bli dags igen.
Ja, att kaffestunden är över.
Ja men jag skulle säga generellt, ja men det har ju gått trög på marknaden.
Från Redpills sida så har investeringar gjorts.
Sen kanske det har så rändrats lite än om man tittar längre tillbaka.
Vi har gjort ganska mycket följdinvesteringar i befintliga portföljbolag.
Så att man behöver hjälpa dem att komma på fötter helt enkelt.
Så att stanna investeringarna upp på grund av makroperspektiv, då är det ganska torligt att det också sker på sällssidan.
Så att man behöver hjälpa bolagen att hitta en cashflowlösning helt enkelt.
Så att vi har gjort ganska många transaktioner de senaste två åren, men vi har också gjort en del nyinvesteringar.
Bland annat i CDLP, i Papershell, bara under det här året.
Så att det rör på oss.
Men jag skulle säga så här att färre bolag har fått en större del utav potten.
Tidigare så har man varit ganska spetig, man har kunnat ta ganska höga risker, man har inte behövt gallra utan man har tittat på mycket möjligheter.
Nu har man blivit mycket mycket snävare och gått på kanske, inte alltid tryggare bolag, men på bolag där man ser en större uppsida.
Så du behöver ju hämta hem också den nominella vinsten som du vill eller räkna på i slutändan då.
Jag tänker på, papercell kan jag inget om, men CDLP kan jag någonting om bara för att jag har hört om hos framtidens e-handel.
Och jag som alla andra som lyssnar på sådana här poddar, går ju in och kollar alla bolag när ett företag presenteras.
Det är ju liksom standard.
Det är ju ett typ DTC, varumärke inom mode som, jag vet jag ska säga fashion för att vi ska prata samma språk här.
Och som har gått minus, det känns liksom som de som inte ska ha pengar.
Vad är det som gör ett sånt, du behöver inte svara om du inte vill, men vad är det som gör ett sånt case ändå attraktivt?
Är det bara för att, fan det här var en god chef typ?
Eller vad är liksom?
Det är de här karismatiska lederna.
Eller är det varumärke?
Vad är det som kan få en investerare att bortser från ett minusresultat under en period när det verkar vara så ultrafokus?
Bra fråga.
Ett minusresultat behöver ju inte bero på att allting har gått jävligt dåligt, utan det kan ju bero på att man har gjort en större satsning så att få en större uppsida i ett tidigare eller ett senare skede.
Jag tror att i CDLPS-fall så lägger man jättestor tilltro till varumärket och hur tidigare marknader har gått.
Och så ser man då, ska du gå in på exempelvis amerikanska marknaden, det är klart att det kostar pengar, men tror vi att vi får igen det slutändan?
Ja men det tror vi.
Det finns ju så många parametrar i det här.
Så har ett annat bolag, vi säger inom hårdvara eller inom mjukvara också för den delen, då kan det ju finnas en jättestor investering, men ett negativt kassaflöde ovanpå det.
Men det finns ett jättehög IPS sida, där det finns jättesolida processer, patent, designskydd och rättigheter som har ett långt mycket högre värde, som då bär en stor del av bolagets värdering, än vad det tillfälliga intäktsströmmen gör.
För att man kanske kommer från en utvecklingsfas eller liknande.
Vi som inte är insatta, vi tänker ju att investerare på något sätt tänker, ja det här bolaget kan ha en successivt ökad omsättningshastighet, som rör sig i någon sorts L-kurva uppåt, och resultatet ska väl följa med förhoppningsvis.
Men det känns ju som en liksom, vi tänker att det är 100 procent av det, men nu pratar du om IP, du pratar om varumärken, du pratar om hur mycket tänker man på sånt, när man letar investeringar, eller letar man efter sådana investeringar bara nu för att det inte finns några omsättningsinvesteringar?
Ja, omsättningsinvesteringar finns, men jag tror att investerare försöker alltid hitta den här balansen och olycksom sweetspotten.
För det handlar ju också om en timing.
För att, ja men du kan ju hitta den här kassaflödespositiva bolagen som har alla den här stabila grunden och utvecklingen är klar, och det finns en marketpull och kunderna är där.
Det är bara att börja skala och prognoserna är solida.
Men det som du får tillbaka som investerare är ju att det blir ganska dyrt många gånger för värderingen är ju skyhög och du kanske hade velat komma in i ett tidigare skede.
För du hade velat ha en mycket, mycket högre hävstångseffekt på din investering för att säg då att du kommer in i ett senare skede och ni ska gå, det här bolaget ska gå på börsen.
Hur många gånger nuvarande värdering räknar man kunna se igenom tre eller fem eller sju år?
Då blir det inte så mycket.
Det blir en trygg investering men den blir inte så stor om vi inte har enorma mängder pengar att gå in med.
Så att hela tiden handlar om de här paraliteterna och omständigheterna för hög risk.
När man tycker att här hade vi velat komma in, vi hade kunnat gambla för att de kommer lösa det här.
Det är ett bra och positivt, kanske negativt kassaflöde utifrån vår egen investeringspreferens för att vi kommer få en större uppsida när vi väl väljer att gå ur i slutändan.
Jag köper det, jag tycker att det är jävligt logiskt och bra förklarat.
Nu vill jag prata negativt om någonting så då använder jag mitt eget företag, för då blir ingen sur.
Men om vi tar gymmekompaniet då, vi är ju ett ganska tråkigt case för en investerare.
Om vi skulle prata, det är väldigt linjärt och det är en ganska lång beställningsperiod och det är ganska små marginaler.
Skulle man skala det så kräver det en del kapital, för det handlar egentligen bara om att köpa lager och långsamt öka på, men det är så långa ledtider.
Då om vi tar till exempel ett mordervarumärke som CDLP som kanske har en större förlust, men de kan skala mycket snabbare, de kan gå internationellt på ett helt annat sätt än vad vi kan på grund av frakter och liknande som inte går att göra.
Om man tillhör den värden av bolag som jag tillhör som typ vitvaror eller, nu kanske det är inte det bästa exemplet, men gymmutrustning och typ ved.
Vart letar man då?
Vem är någonsin intresserade av ett långsamt case?
Finns det sådana?
Ja absolut, det tror jag.
Frågan är väl bara om man får ställa sig tillbaka, om man då är som du, alltså bolagsägare och grundare, behöver vi kapitalet?
För om allting tickar på, är det så att man behöver den där aggressiva skalningen?
Men förutsätt att jag var 65 och jag vill gå i pension, jag vill flytta till Spanien med mina barn.
Ja, ja, ja.
Jo men absolut.
Jag tror att har du den stabila tillväxten och du har ett positivt kassaflöde, oavsett att det är en lågmarginalsbusiness, då kommer du alltid hitta en köpare.
Det tror jag inte kommer vara utmaningen.
Sen kanske det inte är den traditionella, eller liksom den gena som gör själv är inom att man är tech-investerare som har en lite aggressivare approach, man vill kanske att det sitter och hålla på bolag, utan då kanske man snarare får leta efter en helt ny ägare som kan ta över bolaget och driva det i en helt egen regi helt enkelt.
Vad är det som gör att de här traditionella private equity-firmen, AOC-bolagen och liknande, de kanske har en kortare tidshorisont på typ tre till tio år.
Jag generaliserar in alla i ett här.
Men i ditt fall så beskrev du det som att Red Pill Invest är privatpersoner som puttar in en pott och är med.
Har ni en kort tidshorisont och varför?
Jag skulle säga att vi har nog ganska motsvarande tidshorisont som de andra investmentbolagen.
Där handlar det ju om att försöka skaffa en samsyn tillsammans med bolaget.
Vad är det vi vill göra tillsammans?
Vad ser man som en potentiell exitplan?
Många av de här senare bolagen som vi går in i, det kanske är CEC eller senare skede, men då är det ju ganska naturligt att man tittar på en karobös introducering eller liknande.
Då finns det ju alltid en helt annan möjlighet när man tittar på en exitplan, det vill säga att då kan du ju alltid köpa och sälja.
Innan man då eventuellt skulle sälja av ett bolag eller göra den här noteringen, det är klart att en exitsituation uppkommer ju inte för en köpare i andra ledet.
Och där vill man ju gärna göra den exiten tillsammans med bolaget.
Och det som man ser är gynnsamt för bolaget, för det kanske är så att man säljer av en bit av ens innehav, men behåller en liten del.
Men det är ju en ganska demokratisk marknad, för att värderingen sätts ju ut efter att det finns en köpare.
En exit kan du göra när det också finns en köpare.
Så att det är ju, du kan planera mycket, men du kan inte planera allt.
Varför pratar man alltid om börsen som den stora gralen?
Det måste vara rätt få exits som går till börsen.
Ja, men så är det ju verkligen.
Och det är ju inte alltid att börsen är rätt miljö eller för alla bolag.
Så att jag är ganska försiktig med det tycker jag.
Det kommer ju med ett ansvar och det kommer med regulatoriska perspektiv och det kommer till att hela bolaget behöver göra en förflyttning.
Och att byta skede i bolaget är ju lika tufft när du lämnar en utvecklingsfas som en kommersialiseringsfas eller liknande.
Så att, nej det där jag ser på det med ganska nykta ögon tror jag.
För det kommer med...
Är det det entreprenörer och grundare går runt och drömmer om?
Säkert!
Många.
Är det för att ha man lyckat, vad är liksom den stora, jag tycker bara mest verkar krångligt typ.
Ja, det respekterar jag.
Verkar så jävla mycket.
En gång så pratade vi med ett stort annat bolag om vi skulle bli en del av deras koncern.
Detta var många år sedan och det blev ju inget av det.
Men då sa de att då måste du skicka in en massa sådana rapporter och jag kände bara, fan!
Det verkar jobbigt.
Ja, nej då tror jag inte att bästen är rätt miljö.
Men jag tror att någon större eller vanligare dröm hos många entreprenörer är att man gör en total exit.
Man säljer bolaget och sitt ägande och så får man en avkastning på att du har vikt ditt liv åt att bygga ett bolag de senaste åren.
Så jag tror det är nog kanske vanligare bland entreprenörerna.
Vad är din stora drivkraft?
Nu kan det vara både privat och i Red Pill Investor men när du investerar i en entreprenör eller ett företag eller ett team så brukar du liksom känna fan ja det här kan vi tjäna jävligt mycket pengar på eller det här kan bli jävligt bra eller är det mer, fan det här verkar kul eller fan jag tycker om det här.
Alltså vad är din primär, vad är det oftast du går igång på, vilken känsla?
Ja känslan som jag vill komma åt är väl att jag är så jävla besatt av förbättring och utveckling.
Där jag ser att det investerar vi nu eller lyckas det här bolaget med det som de vill åstadkomma då kan det bli en sån jävla smäll utifrån ett positivt sätt.
Den positiva effekten kan ju komma utifrån ett hållbarhetsperspektiv eller att man gör någonting helt revolutionerande för en potentiell kundgrupp eller du kan rädda liv eller vad det nu är att du ligger inom för genren.
Men jag tror att när man väl kommer att få den här emotionella påkopplingen inför en investering, då har du redan verifierat basinformationen och börjat processa och titta på att det här är, vi kan ticka våra boxar.
Men jag tror att den där känslan måste jag känna att jag blir mädryckt och känna att vi kan göra någonting riktigt, riktigt bra.
Inte det är en farlig känsla, man tar ju sämre ekonomiska beslut.
Om man, om man sitter ni liksom, jag bara ser hur ni sitter i någon sorts draknästets style, fyra personer som ska bedöma.
Ja, sitter, så kommer teamet där och pitchar och ni sitter liksom och petar på varandra med en nål så att ni inte ska bli för glada.
Försöker man liksom hålla, försöker ni inte ryckas med eller tycker ni om att ryckas med?
Ja, men där är vi nog, vi kompletterar nog varandra.
Så ni har ett par riktigt tråkiga, torra, empatilösa människor och några som...
Alltså våra aktiva partner är ju Dag Magnis, som har en i ett egen CFO bakgrund.
Så han är den torra?
Ja, men han är en kul CFO.
Det är, alltså han är fantastisk.
Det är ett svarlast jämförelse.
Han är en kul CFO.
Ja, men han är otrolig.
Så, och framförallt, det handlar ju som sagt om att ha dem som kompletterar den på ett bra sätt.
Och sen så har vi Petter Edfeldt som är bolagsjurist och advokat.
Men jag tror att det där med emotional anchoring, jag är en ganska relationell person.
Ganska saklig, ganska resultatriven.
Jag vill se effekt, jag har inga problem att lägga känslorna i sidan.
Men för mig blir det snarare att när jag har den sakliga informationen eller kunskapen till mig märker jag att jag blir emotionellt eller känslomässigt engagerad.
Då är det ett ganska bra kvitto för mig att vi är någonting på spåren.
Sen får man ju alltid balansera och försöka verifiera både det informativa och det kanske mer emotionella tillsammans med andra duktiga personer som man sitter i dialog med.
Men det är nog ganska bra att ha en mix där mellan.
Jag har svårt att se att Red Pill skulle göra en investering bara baserat på business-kriset men där vi inte känner att fan vi blir jävligt engagerade i detta.
Har du inte det engagemanget då kan du inte ta en plats i styrelserummet på goda uppsåt eller sitta med som ett advisor kanske.
Du måste liksom vara med i grunden och ledningen på ett bra och schysst sätt.
Annars så är business-kriset bra så finns det säkert andra investerare som kan hitta det engagemanget istället.
Om folk nu sitter på ett case och man sådär vill pitcha det, vilka är det som ska höra av sig till dig?
Vad är det du, du sa att du går igång på det här med utveckling eller att man förändrar en hel genger kanske eller bransch eller liknande, men vilka företag märker du att du pitchar för gruppen oftast?
Jag, oj, jag tar nog med mig bolag som har en ganska stor impact.
Och det kan vara att de når en jättebra effekt på hållbarhetssidan, eller de kan revolutionera en hel produktgrupp.
De kan gå in i ett marknadssegment som är liksom helt, det har legat liksom i en sövande.
I stiltje.
Exakt, exakt.
Och göra väldigt, väldigt bra saker.
Så att jag vill se ganska, att det finns en ganska hög innovationsgrad.
Då är jag en ganska duktig pitchare internt att ta med mig de bolagen och leda det arbetet.
Sen är det som alltid, man kommer tillbaka till vilka som är grunderna och det som vi tittar på kanske mer och mer är väl att gå in i en senare fase och då vill man gärna se att det finns en eller flera grundare som kanske är serie entreprenörer.
Man har tagit några hårda smälla, det är lessons learned.
Många gånger när man går in och investerar så vill man kanske bortse från de här självklara misstagarna som alla måste göra och som jag också har gjort som entreprenör och där man kan bygga utifrån en annan nivå av entreprenörskap helt enkelt.
Plocka bort barnsjukdomar.
Ja men exakt.
Okej.
Nu sa du lite det som du kanske pitchar in mest, men finns det några grejer som du aldrig skulle pitcha eller finns det några red flags som ni inte går in i eller inte är intresserade av?
Ja vad är vi inte intresserade av?
Jo men det finns väl otroligt mycket man inte är intresserad av.
Där man känner att det här gör ingen förändring för världen, eller det här gör inte gott.
Eller där man känner att det här motsätter en miljöfråga vi är drivna in om, eller det här ställer till med en etisk eller moralisk konflikt, eller vi behöver inte bli utav exysata i världen.
Det är kanske där man kan ställa till och med en fråga kring existensberättigande för vissa bolag på marknaden, utan att vara mer specifik än så.
Jo var specifik, nej du behöver inte vara, jag skojar.
Men där det blir antingen jävligt mycket fluff, eller det blir en greenwashing-fråga, eller där vi känner att då är inte vi rätt pat, så att det finns jättemycket red flags.
Men ofta så kommer man inte ens så långt, utan då tar det ungefär två sekunder att säga tack men nej tack.
Upplever du, jag hade med Josef Faller sen i podden, det var han som hade den här business-podden för länge sen, och han var med och gjorde upp dragnästet lite grann här nu.
Men han sa att när han jobbade som investerare så tyckte han att det var skälardödande, eller för att man sa nej till alla hela tiden.
Kan du känna den känslan?
Ja, man säger otroligt mycket nej, alltså otroligt och det är väl...
Jag försöker se det som så här, ja men visst det kan vara jävligt skälardödande, men det kan också vara en, vad ska man säga, en insikt till entreprenörerna som sitter på andra sidan, men varför fick jag det här nejet?
Är det så att mitt bolag faktiskt inte har ett existensberättigande för att det är ingen som behöver det här?
Eller marknaden är redan full?
Eller marknaden som jag vill gå in i, den är liten?
Eller är det så att business-criset håller inte?
Ja men då är det kanske bra att få de här 100 nian för att jag måste gå tillbaka till skistbordet och fundera på hur fan jag ska hitta ett bättre case.
För att i slutändan säga att du blir beviljad den här investeringen som du är utefter om du gör en ny emission och går ut på marknaden.
I slutändan om inte business-criset håller, då kommer inte dina investerare vara nöjda ändå.
Det är jobbigare att sitta i den dialogen när de väl är inne på cap table än vad det är att få ni från första början att gå tillbaka och rätta till och hitta ett starkare case eller modifiera eller produktutveckla och göra någonting som är bättre, snabbare och mer kvalitetssäkrat.
Så att hellre 100-9 i tidig fas än i senare för då då börjar det bli jobbigt.
Ja exakt, då är man lite mer investerad i det kanske.
Ja men verkligen.
Jag är lite nyfiken på själva processen när folk hör av sig till er.
Finns det liksom en golden standard så här vill man att folk ska höra av sig?
Är det att man ska röra sig i eran parameter liksom under tre år och sen långsamt synas så att ni kontaktar?
Är det den bästa eller ska man ha ett ultra bra pitchdeck på ne ne ne ne ne eller ska man komma via en kontakt sedan?
Vad är liksom det här, såhär tycker vi om när folk gör?
Ja alltså, jag tror vi har försökt formalisera den här resan många gånger från intern sida men sen ser det alltid annorlunda ut.
Någon kommer från sidan och våra investerare kommer in med egna portföljbolag som vi slutar upp med och så vidare.
Men jag skulle säga ganska vanligt är det ju att vi får pro-proer från andra investerare i vårt nätverk som vet vår investeringsfilosofi och vet att vi kanske har rätt investerare bakom oss som kan tillföra någon form av strategisk värde till det här bolaget.
Och så får man ett pitchdeck eller ett IM där man tittar på bolaget.
Vad är det de söker?
Vad är det vi sitter och utvärderar?
Är det rätt fas för oss eller vill vi avvakta?
Vad befinner emissionen sig för i utgångsläge?
Och alla de här faktorerna som gör att man kan göra en bra bedömning helt enkelt.
Oftast har man ju ett första möte med en grundare eller en vd och ibland också tillsammans med exempelvis en marknadschef eller en CFO eller en tekniskchef, lite beroende på vad det bolaget pysslar med då.
Och sen så går man igenom underlag och man genomför en vd-process för att titta på att sitter det här precis så som IM ett presenterar och vad det är vi behöver verifiera eller säkerställa.
Och sen så befinner man sig ofta i någon form av förhandlingssituation där man försöker ta reda på vad omständigheterna för investeringen kommer att handla om.
Är värderingen säkerställd eller finns det ett förhandlingsutrymme?
Hur stor investering tittar vi på och så vidare.
Och det är ju också en process som absolut går att snabba på och vi är ganska snabba, det kan liksom gå på några veckor.
Men den här tiden också ett sätt att ta tempen på samarbetsförmågan och hålla en ganska bra kommunikation med de som sitter på andra sidan.
Vi har ju, vi tycker ju om bra ägarkommunikation och vi vill höra både uppsider och utmaningar för att när vi som sitter inne på ägarlistan då vill vi se både ups och downs för att då får man sluta intern sälja och vi vill vara med och boosta bolaget framåt.
Så att det är väl ungefär så processen ser ut.
Och så fullföljer man investeringen.
Finns det några kritiska ögonblick under den här processen där det ofta faller?
Jag fattar att de ber om 800 miljoner och de är värda två.
Jag fattar det men finns det liksom några grejer som man inte tänker på kanske från andra perspektivet, men som man borde ha tänkt på redan från start.
Om man bortser från själva siffror och värderingsdelarna, så skulle jag säga att det handlar om att försöka inte översälja.
Alltså du ska påvisa möjligheter men...
Går man in sen...
Vi kan typ gå med vinst kanske.
Ja men exakt, exakt.
Och där man säger att vi går in och tittar specifikt kring produktutvecklingen eller vad det tekniskt ska befinna sig i för fas.
Och det visar sig att så är det ju inte alls.
Här fanns det ju liksom mycket större utmaningar och de där patenten var inte beviljade eller man är inte redo för exuserte utfall som man ändå har byggt en prognos för ska infalla imorgon.
Ja men då befinner vi ju oss i ett konstigt läge.
Inte för att vi inte kan ta den tekniska utmaningen, utan för att förtroendet blir skadat.
Så att där gäller det ju att kunna hantera en transparens och en autenticitet från bolagets sida och kunna vara öppen med att det här är utmaningen, det här är statisen och det här är vägen framåt.
Hur väger det ihop med det?
Det måste ju ändå finnas någon sorts, inte charm det är väl inte det man letar efter, men det måste ju ändå finnas någon sorts vision hos grundargänget.
Ni vill väl ändå se passion kring, jag bara tänker vad går balansen mellan att ja men fan vi har inte fixat det här riktigt än och vi ska bli störst i världen.
Vill man inte ha folk som är lite over the top?
Jo men det är klart man vill och det där drivet och nästan övertron måste ju alltid finnas.
För annars så orkar du inte heller driva bolag, du måste ju vara extremt missionsdriven.
Och det är absolut det man vill se.
Men det man vill se är ju kanske att den där tillfälliga utmaningen är bara ett sandkorn i en öken.
Så snart kommer det komma nya utmaningar.
Men är vi med på ägarlistan då?
Då tar vi oss an dem tillsammans.
Så det handlar nog bara om att vara öppen med dem, sätta dem i en kontext, kommunicera hur de ska hanteras och vad vägen framåt är.
Så att det är aldrig en väg att dölja eller försöka översälja vad nuvarande status är.
Då skjuter man sig ut foten för det kommer en duktig investerare att hitta under den här dd-processen.
Då har det slösat både med din egen tid som entreprenör men också investerarnas tid.
Då är man ju borta ifrån en senare eventuell investeringsdialog om man skulle komma in i ett senare skede.
Men jag tror att man behöver titta på investeraren som går in som en partner och då löser vi det här.
Men ni måste också vara förstående inför att problem kommer komma hela tiden.
Man är entreprenörskap och det känner du säkert till själv också att det är ju ett ändå stort problemlösande.
Vi har bara haft smooth sailing här i åtta år.
Nonstop chill.
Absolut, varje dag är det halv skit.
Vi pratar lite kort om det förut men jag tänker bara lite avslutningsvis vem borde ta in kapital och vem borde inte ta in kapital.
Så inte ur er synvinkel utan från entreprenörens sida.
De som borde ta in kapital är ju de som står inför där man vill bygga ett bolag som har en ganska aggressiv skalning eller där det krävs stora investeringar för att komma igång och för att realisera över huvud taget.
Det kan vara en jättehög innovationsgrad men då är det klart att någon måste kunna bedriva den utvecklingen.
Då tycker jag att man ska titta på extant kapital.
Sen behöver det inte alltid vara en investering som säger, det finns ju andra finansiella möjligheter också.
Men jag tror också att man ska titta på investerare som vill ha med en partner i detta.
Vad kan den här investeraren, oavsett hur stor eller liten, öppna för dörrar?
Behöver ju en investerare som har kännedom om en viss marknad eller en viss typ av nätverk som jag vill komma in i.
För en investerare kan ju också vara en kund, det kan vara ett joint ventures, det kan vara liksom ett investeringsarm i en viss koncern där du har en jättestor del av din kundgrupp exempelvis.
Det där ju, jag tycker man ska titta, kan röra främst på det som du vill ha in extremt kapital, men vad för kapital vill du ha?
Vad är det för, utöver pengarna, vad ska kapitalet göra för dig?
Jag lyssnar ju på typ tre timmar på den dagen, men då säger alltid investerare så, vad för kapital, hur fan ska man få reda på vad det är?
Alltså liksom, om jag går in på er hemsida, och jag går in på någon annans hemsida, så är det alltid så där, ja vi hjälper till och vi finns där, och vi kan öppna det.
Från min synvinkel så ser det ut som alla är ganska trevliga.
Hur ska jag som entreprenör kunna veta vad ett företag, eller måste jag gå och träffa alla de här människorna?
Är det bara så?
Ja, om du lyckas få till möte med alla också.
Ja, såklart, såklart, ja.
Eller har ni olika inriktningar som är väldigt tydliga, bara för att jag inte har varit inne i den svängen som jag inte känner till?
Är det så det ser ut?
Man kan liksom, ja de här är bra på USA, de här är bra på Tyskland, de här är bra på Kina.
Är det så det ser ut liksom?
Alltså så kan det ju vara.
Sen kan det ju vara så att vissa investerare går bara in i SaaS-bolag exempelvis.
Då kan man tänka sig att de som jobbar i det här specifika investeringsbolaget har jättemycket insikt om hur andra SaaS-bolag eller mjukvarubolag har bemött olika skalningsutmaningar.
Det här tar vi med oss ifrån de här andra portföljbolagen.
Så kan man ta med sig de lessons learned in i styrelserummet eller som ett advisory om de investerar i ditt bolag exempelvis.
Så det är ju någon form av matchmaking som ska ske, absolut.
Sen finns det ju de som är jättegeneralister och det finns ju uppsida med det också, men jag tror att där finns det nog kanske inte något enkelt svar, utan det är personkännedom, personkemi och också en hel del research som ska till.
Men mitt tips där skulle vara att titta på ditt eget bolag och titta på ett bolag som du gärna ser upp till eller tar rygg efter.
Det behöver inte ens vara en bransch.
Ta reda på hur deras ägarlista ser ut och hur man har byggt en skalningstrategi eller dels vad man har som representanter på ägarlistan och se om de skulle vara eller vantas för din egen del.
Bra tips.
När ni har gått in i ett bolag och man, vad ska man säga, när ni liksom gjort er matchmaking process och allting är klart och de inte behöver hyckla längre, de behöver inte göra sitt sälj.
Vad är oftast de största problemen som ni tar i tur med direkt eller som ni liksom brukar peka på?
Det här skulle vi vilja.
Nu förstår jag att ni har väldigt olika genrer av investeringar och liknande.
Men finns det några grejer som ofta är underutvecklat av entreprenörer?
Ja, det som vi ofta går in och tittar på det är väl att man följer prognos.
Och att man inte skjuter på resultaten som man vill se.
För då skjuter man ju på hela business-kriset.
Det man kanske vill se är att man fullföljer planen som man har presenterat.
Och det kan ju vara att man ska göra en varumärkesförflyttning eller du ska nå ett intäktsmål eller du ska kunna göra en produktlansering eller ja, valskita annat.
Men att, har vi vad vi behöver för att uppnå de gatesen?
För annars så kommer det bli ett jävligt tufft då nästa år.
Och bolaget då dessutom inför flera kapitalanskaffningar.
Ja men då kommer ju nästa investeringskull eller för den delen befintliga ägare att fråga sig att, ja men ni nådde inte förra årets leverans.
Varför kommer ni göra det i näst kommundår?
Vad säger att det är, att man följer prognos nu?
Och då gäller det att man har ett jävligt bra svar.
Och ofta så finns det ju det.
För det kan röra sig om makroperspektiv eller att det var en svårare utvecklingsfas.
Eller mer avancerad utvecklingsteknik som låg till grunder för att vi skulle lyckas med att hamna på den här tekniska plattformen.
Men det gör att vi har en större brygga från konkurrenterna.
Eller vi har ett starkare skydd nu i vårt IP eller liknande.
Så ofta finns det ju bra argument.
Men det gäller ju att man har hjärnkoll.
Alltså så otroligt solid kontroll över den totala processen.
För annars så är det svårt att vara betrodd i nästkommande tid eller emission eller liknande.
Jag tänker såklart inga namn sådär.
Men liksom, hur bemöter du?
Du har ju suttit i en del styrelser och givetvis träffar du mycket entreprenörer och grundare.
Och de kan ju ha en del, jag kan ju bara titta på mig själv, de kan ju ha en del auktoritetsproblem eller kanske vissa narcissistiska drag.
Att det här är mitt företag, det här är min värld, jag gör som jag vill.
Alltså det är bara så jag intalar mig själv att folk tänker.
Och så ser man kanske lite grann som att ja men du som investerare ska vara nöjd att du får vara med här, eller lite den.
Man kanske säljer in det på ett annat sätt, men sen tänker man ändå att det är ens egna bolag.
Hur ofta blir det liksom en konflikt mellan investerare och entreprenörer och hur förhåller man sig i den balansen?
Är det knepigt eller är det bara det är lugnt liksom, det är business?
Nej men jag tror för vår egen, vi är nog ganska förskonade, det är klart om man hör mycket, men vi är nog ganska förskonade.
Jag tror att som alla mänskliga relationer så får man ju ta reda på vad de bakomliggande argumenten för den approachen i så fall skulle vara.
Är det så att man känner att man förlorar kontrollen?
Är det att bolaget driver sig mot ett håll som inte var den ursprungliga tanken när bolaget startades?
Jag tror att någonstans äga en bra och fungerande läge, kommunikationen nycklar till jävligt mycket.
Nu är du i väldigt korrekt svar men förhoppningsvis ska man inte hamna i det läget.
Någonstans får man nog köpa lite också läget när man är i ytterligheterna med pionjärsbolag som ska revolutionera hela marknaden och liksom hög innovationsgrödet.
Vi är olika och med det kommer en rad olika personlighetsdrag också men det är också många gånger nyckel.
Faktorerna för att också lyckas.
Sen om du tycker det är jobbigt, buckle up.
För det är det vi behöver hantera nu.
Vad behöver den här personen för stöttning?
Det kanske är så att det behöver ledarskap utvecklas eller att man kanske behöver ta grunden och försätta dem på en annan position, en vd positionen för att man behöver en mer human driv person i samhället.
Gud alltså det kan ju vara en sån här åtgärd.
Men jag tror att någonstans så är du inne som investerare, då får du lite köpa läget att försöka förstå vad som ligger bakom ett visst beteende och sen får man försöka stötta och hantera.
Men det är ganska sällan som det har kommit till att det är någon form av kryshantering utan jag skulle säga att det är ganska svårt att passera en hel investeringsprocess för de flesta stora investerare, där man lyckas skåda att spela sig igenom.
För att många investerare är duktiga, människor känner det också.
Vad kul, om man vill ha kontakt med dig eller er, hur gör man?
Ja, då når man mig Lina Valmande på LinkedIn eller så går man in på rpinvest.se.
Gött, då hoppas vi att folk gör det.
Stort tack för att du var med och svarade på alla våra frågor om investeringar.
Om man tillhör den världen av bolag som jag tillhör, som typ vitvaror, eller nu kanske det inte är det bästa exemplet, men gymutrustning och typ ved.